[Musica]
siamo abituati a immaginare le vittorie
e le sconfitte come dei momenti precisi
brevi che accadono nella nostra vita nel
nostro quotidiano
nel nostro percorso sportivo le
visualizziamo spesso attraverso la
metafora dell'ottovolante dove le
vittorie sono i picchi verso l'alto e le
sconfitte sono dei punti più bassi le
picchiate in profondità momenti di
brevissima durata
immaginate l'atleta olimpico che si
ritrova sul podio e finalmente al collo
quel loro tanto agognato in quel momento
sta assaporando la vittoria ma
sicuramente dietro di lui nel suo
percorso le sconfitte sono state tante
il percorso di oggi proveremo invece a
vedere quando la sconfitta arriva in un
momento del tutto inaspettato quando la
sconfitta arriva prima ancora che la
partita comincia sono nato con una
malformazione congenita alla gamba
destra e questo spiega l'utilizzo della
presentazione e delle immagini uno senza
una gamba non può certo parlare a
braccio
va da sé la vita mi ha presentato il
conto prima ancora di poterla cominciare
ora non è che la vita fosse uno schifo
quando era un ragazzino
semplicemente non mi stava dando tutto
quello che potevo prendere da essa cosa
capita quando perdi prima ancora di
cominciare
beh allora cominciamo a parlare un po di
me così riusciamo a entrare dentro
questo percorso ok e io ero il prototipo
dello sfigato
inutile girarci intorno alzi la mano chi
di voi è stato preso in giro almeno una
volta coraggio non siate timidi rivedo
vi vedo tanto non è che il video poi
finisce su the duck se lo vedono milioni
di persone
resta inter nos ok bene allora io ero il
prototipo dello sfigato del perdente
perché si può vedere nell'immagine qui
sopra che l'aria non fosse nelle più
intelligenti l'abbigliamento nemmeno
oltre a ciò io avevo l'occhiale avevo
l'apparecchio
insomma ero un collezionista di motivi
per cui essere preso in giro
aggiungendo tutto ciò io camminavo male
correvo poco è saltato 0 bene oggi siamo
abituati a misurare l'apprezzamento
delle persone con i like che riceviamo
in questo mondo social nel quale viviamo
all'epoca non c'erano i like c'erano le
telefonate e le telefonate degli amici
per poter uscire il pomeriggio e fare
sport assieme né ricevevo 0 per non
parlare delle ragazze insomma facciamo
perdere bene perché questo capitava
perché io pensavo a me stesso come a
quella gamba mancante
io sintetizzando ero la mia gamba quando
mi svegliavo la mattina era lei che
pensavo alla mia diversità alla
differenza tra me e tutte le altre
persone alla mia gamba
io davo un sacco di colpe davo la colpa
di non uscire con quelle ragazzine davo
la colpa alla mia gamba ad esempio non
lo so per i genitori che litigavano in
casa ma possiamo anche salire su più
larga scala
l'italia uscita dai mondiali colpa della
mia gamba
la guerra in iraq colpa della gamba
e così avanti così insomma ecco quello
che vi raccontavo primo alla vita non
era esattamente la cosa più bella che io
stessi vivendo fino a quel momento
poi però capita qualcosa capitano due
incontri che cambiano questo percorso
gli incontri si fanno con le persone e
sono le persone che possono cambiare il
corso di una vita intera e lo possono
fare
agendo nella loro maniera più naturale
nel quotidiano
questi due incontri avvengono in due
contesti totalmente diversi
il primo è a budrio bologna centro
protesi il luogo per intenderci dove
alex zanardi è ritornato a camminare
e un luogo a due facce una due facce
della stessa moneta potremmo dire dove
da una parte abbiamo innovazione
tecnologia robotica sperimentazione i
presidi più all'avanguardia e l'altra
invece è nettamente più di taglio
ospedaliero indovinate un po doveri
capito io la seconda benissimo
ok dicevamo l'ospedale immaginatevi
questo centro protesi enorme
immaginatevi un corridoio infinito con
alla sinistra di questo corridoio i
laboratori nei quali vengono costruiti
gli invasi e le protesi che poi vanno
sulle persone
dentro ci sono questi operai che
rigorosamente parlano soltanto bolognesi
perché ovviamente cosa volete che sia da
quelle parti alla destra del corridoio
ci sono invece dei piccoli stanzini nei
quali le persone provano queste protesi
prima di poter poi tornare a casa
io sono con mamma e papà è solo
all'interno di uno di questi stanzini
immaginatevi una stanza buia con un paio
di neon l'armadietto per costruire i
gessi una sedia davanti a me c'è una
ragazza avrà all'incirca 14 16 anni io
ne ho un paio o meno di lei in questa
ragazza ha una particolarità e senza un
braccio ed essenza anche l'altro braccio
ed è senza una gamba ed essenza anche
l'altra gamba
mamma e papà la prendono da sotto le
ascelle e la spostano dal lettino alla
sedia per farle provare le protesi
anch'io sono con mamma papà ma lei
rispetto a me fa qualcosa di incredibile
se fossimo in un video di innovation
deep ed ex diremmo una cosa a disruptive
ok fa qualcosa di incredibile che mi
cambia la vita per sempre
ride ride di gusto
ride perché dimostra di amare la sua
vita e lo fa con semplicità con gioia
con generosità anch'io sono lì con mamma
e papà ma non ho lo stesso approccio
quel momento li segna per sempre un
cambio fondamentale nel mio modo di
percepire la mia vita
essere su questa terra io capisco di non
avere fondamentalmente niente se lei sta
bene con il suo corpo nonostante tutto
se lei approccia in quel modo alla vita
e ride
ed è così serena la mia vita può essere
fighissima il secondo cambiamento grande
che avviene avviene grazie a un
professore di educazione fisica il
professor morra che ancora ringrazio
professor morra intuisce pre primo
rispetto ad altri che per uscire da
questo imbarazzo questa indifferenza
questa difficoltà nel vivere il mio
corpo c'è bisogno di qualcosa un mezzo e
questo mezzo e il pallone da
pallacanestro che mi ritrovo in mano e
che da quel giorno iniziò a utilizzare
tirandolo e tirando tirando tirando vivo
per 24 anni
tirando a canestro nella gioia più
totale basate bene ho detto tirando non
facendo canestro la pallacanestro non mi
ha salvato la vita
la pallacanestro me l'ha regalata una
molto più bella
rispetto a quella che stavo vivendo fino
a quel momento il cambio si spiega in un
condizionamento e io ho subito
attivamente durante questo periodo di 24
anni perché capite bene che mentre si
gioca a pallacanestro
non si contano quante gambe stanno sotto
i calzoncini una due non importa si è
concentrati a fare ciò che si ama ciò
che la passione guida in quel momento
quindi attaccare e difendere prendere
rimbalzi rubare palla io sono talmente
concentrato nel fare quello che amo che
non penso a quante gambe sono sotto i
calzoncini e il condizionamento e come
un vaso comunicante che inizia a
fecondare altre sfere del mio essere
vivente entra nella sfera personale in
quella professionale
scopro l'amore e la scopro grazie a
questo condizionamento che inizia a come
una goccia a scavare dentro di me ea
costruire quella galleria di emozioni
che mi porta oggi a essere qui davanti a
voi io inizio a svegliarmi la mattina e
non pensare più
di essere quella gamba inizio a smettere
di pensare solo a lei
ora quando mi sveglio alla mattina penso
anche a tutto il resto del mio corpo
questo cambiamento epocale è dovuto al
condizionamento mi ha portato ad essere
la persona che sono oggi cioè qualcosa
in più di quella gamba che tanto mi ha
caratterizzato per tanto tempo oggi sono
mi ritengo insomma una persona normale
sono essenzialmente un marito un papà un
professionista sul lavoro ed è questo il
grande risultato che credo di aver
ottenuto sono soprattutto una persona e
non una persona con un handicap quella
che era la mia sconfitta con la quale
questo percorso che ho voluto
condividere con voi oggi è cominciata è
diventata la mia vittoria nel quotidiano
una vittoria che è stata costellata da
un sacco di dubbi e di domande sarebbe
impossibile non non citarle una
soprattutto è la domanda delle domande
ma ora che sei sereno e sei felice con
il tuo corpo la tua vita sarebbe stata
più bella se avesse avuto due gambe
avresti raggiunto gli stessi risultati
che hai raggiunto in presenza di una
sola è una domanda che tipicamente mi
fanno i bambini ma che anch'io su di me
ho rivolto a me stesso mille volte per
anni io ho risposto
2 che ipocrisia ovviamente due perché
comunque avrei potuto raggiungere gli
stessi risultati o se no anche di più in
presenza di due gambe
negli anni poi ho cambiato questa
visione in fondo se sono qui oggi lo
devo a quella gamba che non c'è se ho
fatto mille cose nella mia vita
personale e professionale e sportiva
lo devo a quel handicap che tanto mi
vergognava quando ero ragazzino
eppure c'è un terzo modo di intendere le
cose
una terza via ora che the backs sarebbe
se non ci fosse almeno una citazione
impossibile allora attingiamo dal mondo
delle citazioni e condividiamo né una di
beans lombardi allenatore della nfl che
negli anni 60
ha vinto tre titoli nfl con i green bay
packers miss lombardi papà enrico
lombardi e mamma marina izzo chiare
origini italiane così restiamo in un
tema local come il tex bene vis lombardi
diceva la misura di ciò che siamo e ciò
che facciamo con quel che abbiamo questo
sintetizza tanto del messaggio che io
vorrei condividere con voi oggi passiamo
gran parte del nostro tempo concentrati
a cercare quello che sta fuori noi
stessi quello che non abbiamo
passiamo gran parte del nostro tempo a
cercare di essere qualcosa che non siamo
a possedere qualcosa o qualcuno che non
è con noi quando in realtà per
raggiungere determinati obiettivi
importanti nella nostra vita
quello che dobbiamo fare e massimizzare
noi stessi massimizzare significa andare
in cerca del top di e belle meglio di
qualsiasi cosa possa essere prossima
alla perfezione
eppure sempre vins lombardi incitazione
numero 2 dice la perfezione non è di
questo mondo non l'ha detto solo lui ma
è inseguendo la perfezione che otteniamo
l'eccellenza e l'eccellenza è ciò che
domina tutto quello che io ho fatto in
questi anni a livello sportivo
al punto che poi altre domande che ho
ricevuto specie dagli amici che mi
conoscono meglio sono state del tipo ma
tu perché lo fai
soprattutto perché lo fai con questa
intensità ma che cosa vuoi dimostrare
vuoi dimostrare di superare determinati
limiti per te stesso per gli altri
perché ti sta intorno
la domanda come una bomba etichettato
dentro di me per anni e finalmente poi
ne è uscita una risposta perché o nel
ricevere una domanda del genere non sono
riuscito a rispondere subito ci ho
riflettuto molto e ho giocato 24 anni a
pallacanestro e ho giocato a basket in
piedi con persone con due gambe bipedi
grazie
mi vengono così su due piedi per dieci
anni ho corso con il quad e non è un
corso nel giardino di casa ma ho fatto
gare internazionali o corso cinque volte
il mondiale nella categoria handicap
l'ho vinto tre per due volte sono
arrivato secondo
tornando a parlare di pallacanestro ho
girato un video con la nazionale
italiana di pallacanestro
mi sono allenato con la serie a insomma
non riesco mai a toccarla piano oggi
pratico crossfit e lo pratico con
un'intensità pari a quella che ho svolto
nelle altre discipline e questo mi ha
portato a partecipare come primo
disabile in italia ad una manifestazione
di crossfit e tante altre saranno le
porte che spero di aprire prossimamente
allora perché questa intensità
il motivo che lega queste tre discipline
che spiega perché io ho scelto di fare
questo e magari non giocare a scacchi
con tutto il rispetto per gli scacchi o
giocare a curling e perché questi tre
sport hanno un fil rouge che li accomuna
ed è la possibilità che mi danno di
andare a toccare veramente quelle che
sono le mie debolezze le mie difficoltà
io credo che per diventare la versione
possibile di noi stessi l'obiettivo è lo
scopo di questa missione che abbiamo e
confrontarci con quelle che sono le
nostre parti intime peggiori con lato
oscuro che noi abbiamo i buchi di
sceneggiatura le manchevolezze i difetti
solo così possiamo migliorare noi stessi
lavorando sullo young sulla parte
peggiore di noi ora abbiamo iniziato
questo percorso con la figura
dell'ottovolante quei picchi in altri
picchi in basso momenti piccoli momenti
ok picchi che svaniscono in un attimo
pensate alla parola successo l'italiano
in questo ci aiuta e un participio
passato per la parola succedere e non a
caso è passato è successo è finito
bisogna già pensare a quello a quello
che viene dopo
vittorie sconfitte sono spesso viste
come dei piccoli momenti ma in realtà
possiamo unirli tutti insieme e
comprendere che il percorso è molto più
grande da una singola vittoria o da una
singola sconfitta
tutta la vita può prendere un
significato diverso è quella che
all'inizio era una sconfitta può
diventare una vita intera legata alla
vittoria perché le vittorie non esistono
se non esiste anche una bella sana dose
di sconfitte grazie grazie
[Applauso]